>> TERRISTWILL DIE AND G TO
HELL.BIDEN TAS AICTORY L BUT
THE ARE NEW CONRNS AT
HAVEN FO TERROSTSONCE USA B LAD
COMMAND H WASILLED BY A DRONE
STRIKEHILETANDING ON A
BALCONY I KAB.
THE C TRACKEDHISERRORIST
R MONTH BEFE TAKING THE
OU IN A WEALTHYREA ERE HEWAS STT
THE HOME OF NATEO A TALAN
INHE OPEN RAISES ALAS THT
AL QDA CLD BE MAKING A
COBACK IN GHANTAN FOR THE
WHITE HOUS SAY--
WENOW THEALIBAN W
HARBING THE WORLD MOS
WAED TERRIST.
YOU GUYS GE A WHOLE COUNTRY T
BUNCH OPEOPHAT A ON
THEBI'S MOS WAND LIST.
HAPPEN?D YOUHINKAS CAN
REI TAKE ISSUE WH THE
PRESEN-- INCOURAGEOU TO
ASK  THEAY YOU ASK THAT IT
MAKE IT SOUND LIKE WE OWNED
AFGHANTAN YEAR AGOIT WASN'UR CNY
IT WASN INDEPENDENT SEREI
STE.
THE PSIDE MADE T BD
CISI TO E AAR THATAD
EN GNG ON FOR 20EARS.
DEPART AHANIAN WERE GOING T
KEEP VIGIL ANDIDN' STAYEADY
AND WE AROT GNG TLETAFGHANISN BN
FOR TRORIS TO THREATEN THE
HOMELAND.
>> I AAYS WAS.WE DON'TOANT ON AD
LOT OF MOY FO IT FOR A LONTI SE
LONG-TERLEAS
DON'T IT ALWAY BEEN HAVEN
FO TERRORISTS?
WHEN D WEVER THINK --
>> OF COUR NOT
WHETHER WE SHOD PL OUT O AN
TCOMOF THAT DEBAT IS OVE
COMMITTEESITHE PRESIDE IS
GOINTO POREOLDIERS BK
INTELLIGENCE A IN FOR ANDSTILL E
SCLE
THE THINGS JUSTLACEOU UP
LIKE THAT.
DOE'T EVEN EXPLOD
LOV I
I'D WI I'DNOWN AUT THI
BEFO I WLD'VE BEEN TKING
SO WERE GOING TO S I TNK WE
SHLD ASSUME THAT BUD WEUST
HA TOEEP OUR EYES OTHESURVEILLCE
CH EXTENSIVE SATELTES
IF ALLF A SUDDEHATE
THINKS THE ANDT MAKES YOU
INK YOU'RE NOTITTI UP IN
THE NORERNRIANGLE  JUS
SOUTHERN BORR.HUNDREDSFHOUSANDSA
WAYSVERY SINE MONTH
ME TERRORIST FM AFGHANISTAN
HAS CROSSED INTO O SOUERN
BORD AND/OR COUNTRIN T
BIN ADMINISTRATN ISOT DONE
ANYTNG ABOUT I
ABOUT I TO THIS PNT WHAT IS
THELAN ING FORWD.
MUC AS PEOPLE ADMIRDMIR
RBY
N WE AS ALAN FOR WT MIGBE BREWIN
SPECICALLY MTION OTHER
THAN THE PLOOF AFGHASTANAS
QUESTIONED BECAUSE CRY OUT
THESE TACK BEAR THEWHE HOE IS UT
D GRT FOR TH WOR TO SAY
AT PLAN ISORKI.
WAY OUT OF T ONEEAR THEIR
ANNIRSAR OF THEATASOPHIC
WIDRAWAL WCH I AOMPLE
THERE SLL PPLERAPP HERE
WH COULDN'T T O.
OPLEHO HELPE US  THE WAR
AND IT DSN'TXCUSE DIED.
DSN'T EXCE TH BUT I WASTHINKINP
ANDHEYID THEIG RE GARDEN
CEREMO ANDACE SO THAT IS
TH REALLY AZING THING AND
THEN PEOPLASKI QSTIO
OUT WHAT ACTUAY HAPPENED.
GREASTRI, GLAD HE'S DEAD.
THE CT TTE W RAISE LOT
OFUESTNSBOUT WT'S
HAPPENG TH AL QAED IS T
CONSTUTING ITSELF THERE
IS MNINGE SAID HEAS
TIVE PLANNING ATTKS.
AT'S A VERY GO TNGND T
KE SOLERSFF THE GROUND WE.
>> THA ISBVIOUSLY TOOUR
DID THE BOTCHE WHDRAL HAVE
IMPACT ON WHELT CONFIDENT
RENSTITING OVE THE?
IFE HAD GOTTEN O
DIERENY WOULD WE HAV HAD A
FFERENT OUTCOMIN W THEY
E RIGHT NOW?
>> WE DNOWERRORISTS ARE
ABOUT THINGS HEREE FEEL
A HERITAGE EVERYWHERE ARE SAYG
OUT H WE E HANDLIUR
FOREIGOLIC PITION --
EVERNE WAS TALKINGBOUTOW
WEREEAKER FOR THE WAY TT
ITAS DONE, NOTHAT  WASN'T
THEY A CTAINLY MSURI
TH ANDO ADD TOATIE'S POINT
ABOUT HOW SHE W JUSHANGING
T AT OUR BALCONY A IN THE
PITALISIFE AND DAUGHR
THEY WERE JT ROANG AUND
LIKEORMA PEOPLEHERES
LL.
AND  KNO HOWALUABLE
TERRORIS.IN THESEINDS OF
WHAT IHINKS INTERESNG
OKIN FORWARD I WHAT'S NEXT
FOR AL QAEDSO THEUMBER THREE GUE
ACTUALLY LES IN IRAN, WHI
EATES A WLE OTHER
COLICATION INTO THI SOEOPLE
OF QUESTION S CDIBILITYN
TERMS  COMG TO THE TOP O
TH HEAT  DOES TSEAN THAT
RIGHT?GOING TBE SNDING,
D WERE GNG TA CONFLUENCE
OF TSE EIGHT -- WELL IS
THIS -- YOU SLEUT JUS TO
DIRACT FROM A HORRIE SERS
NEW-ECAU WE AREEARING
AT THE CIA H EYELLS IN
TH FORONTHS AN MONS.
D Y KNOW THEY HAD DELOP
BACALLA PERSONALITY OFIL
WAS DOING IT.G A WHEN HE
THEYNEWHERE HE WAS, THEY
BUILT A MOD OF E PLACE HE
WASTAYIN.
SOHE STRIK COMT A CURIOTI.
KATIE BRIS UHEOTCHED
WIDRAWAL WASBVIOUS O YR
O.
ISHIS A WAY TO NOT ONLY
DISTCT B AO FOR SOME OFTHESE HOM
OF GDP AND INSLLATION?
>> I DON'TNOW.
IT'S LIKEHE MIA WAS DNG T
ITE THOSEOE H HIS GROOVEBACK ARE
ALMOSTREWRTEN, LIK
OBITRIES.
ITIND OFOUND LIKE IT IN
WAY.
OFF THIS GUY W HANNG OUTSED
CASULYOR H LON
WHAT IN G'S NES A WHITE
SUPREMACISDOININ
NEVER GOES AWAY.HAT TRORI
WHEN THAT SFF HAPNS UNDER
PRESENT THAT'S ON EM A
WH GOOD SFF HAPPENS UNDER
EM WE BLE TH DEMRATS.
THIN YOU HAVE TOIVEHEM
CREDIT, BUT E PBLEM WIT
JO WHAS HARD ABOUT GIVG
EMREDIT IS THATEEFUS
SPONSIBITY F THE BAD
UFF.
SO IS KINDF HD WHEN
SOMETHING OD HPENS TO PAT
THEM OTHEACK EVEN THOU I
INKE SHOUL EVE THOUGHE
KNOW THAT HE PROBLYAD VY
LILE TO DOITHHIS.
HE WAS KEPT IN THE DARIKE ARA M.
HE WASOTAL AGAINSTS
LLING USAMA BILADE
I DON'T KNOIT VER LUCKY --
BUT DO TNK IS A CAU FOR
CELEATION WNOMEBODY LIKE
THIS TS IN VER RUCTA TO
TURN GOOD WS ANDO TT GIVEN
OICES I'D RATHER HAVE
AL-ZAHIRI DE THA ALIVE.
WISH WE KL TM 20 OR0
YES AGO WHEN HEAS IHIS